une augmentation du rythme cardiaque, et nous transpirons.
Alors que les psychopathes dans notre étude ont pu
décrire les photos avec précision,
ils n'ont pas réussi à montrer les émotions requises.
Ils n'ont montré aucune réaction physique.
C'était comme s'ils savaient les mots
mais pas la musique de l'empathie.
Nous avons donc voulu examiner ça de plus près
pour utiliser l'IRM afin de représenter leurs cerveaux.
Cela s'est avéré être une tâche difficile.
Imaginez devoir transporter un groupe
de psychopathes cliniques à travers Londres,
enchaînés et menottés
à l'heure de pointe,
et pour placer chacun d'entre eux dans un scanner IRM,
vous devez retirer tous les objets métalliques,
y compris les chaînes et les menottes,
et comme je l'ai appris, tous les piercings.
Après un certain temps, cependant, nous avons eu un début de réponse.
Ces personnes n'étaient pas seulement les victimes
d'une enfance difficile.
Il y avait quelque chose d'autre.
Des gens comme Joe ont un déficit dans une zone du cerveau
appelée l'amygdale.
L'amygdale est un organe en forme d'amande
au fond des hémisphères du cerveau.
On pense que c'est la clé pour pouvoir ressentir de l'empathie.
Normalement, plus une personne est empathique,
plus l'amygdale est grande et active.
Notre population de détenus
avait une amygdale déficiente,
ce qui a probablement conduit à leur manque d'empathie
et à leur comportement immoral.
Alors prenons un peu de recul.
Normalement, l'acquisition de comportement moral
fait tout simplement partie de la croissance,
comme apprendre à parler.
À l'âge de six mois, presque chacun d'entre nous
est capable de faire la différence entre objets animés et inanimés.
À l'âge de 12 mois,
la plupart des enfants sont capables d'imiter
les actions finalisées des autres.
Ainsi, par exemple, votre mère lève les mains
pour s'étirer et vous imitez son comportement.
Dans un premier temps, ce n'est pas parfait.
Je me souviens de mon cousin Sasha,
qui avait deux ans à l'époque,
regardant un livre d'images
et léchant un doigt et tournant la page de l'autre main,
léchant un doigt et tournant la page de l'autre main.
(Rires)
Peu à peu, nous construisons les bases de notre cerveau social
de sorte que lorsque nous avons trois ou quatre ans,
la plupart des enfants, pas tous,
ont acquis la capacité de comprendre
les intentions des autres,
une autre condition préalable à l'empathie.
Le fait que ce développement progressif
est universel,
quel que soit l'endroit où vous vivez dans le monde
ou quelle que soit la culture dans laquelle vous vivez,
suggère fortement que les bases
de la moralité sont innées.
Si vous en doutez,
essayez, comme je l'ai fait, de revenir sur une promesse
que vous avez faite à un enfant de quatre ans.
Vous verrez que l'esprit d'un enfant de quatre ans
n'est pas naïf du tout.
Il s'apparente davantage à un couteau suisse
avec des modules mentaux fixés,
aiguisés au cours du développement
et un sens aigu de l'équité.
Les premières années sont cruciales.
Il y a une fenêtre d'opportunité,
après quoi la maîtrise des questions morales
devient plus difficile,
comme les adultes qui apprennent une langue étrangère.
Cela ne veut pas dire que c'est impossible.
Une récente étude merveilleuse de l'Université de Stanford
a montré que les personnes qui ont joué
un jeu de réalité virtuelle dans laquelle ils ont pris
le rôle d'un bon et serviable super-héros
devenaient en fait plus attentionnés et serviables
envers les autres après le jeu.
Maintenant, je ne dis pas que
nous donnsons aux criminels des super-pouvoirs,
mais je dis que nous devons trouver des moyens
d'obtenir que Joe et des gens comme lui
changent leur cerveau et leur comportement,
à leur profit
et pour le bénéfice du reste d'entre nous.
Alors, les cerveaux peuvent-ils changer ?
Pendant plus de 100 ans,
les neuroanatomistes et les neuroscientifiques plus tard
étaient d'avis qu'après le développement initial pendant l'enfance,
aucune nouvelle cellule ne pouvait croître
dans le cerveau humain adulte.
Le cerveau ne pouvait changer que
dans certaines limites fixées.
C'était le dogme.
Mais alors, dans les années 1990,
des études ont commencé à montrer,
à l'instar d'Elizabeth Gould à Princeton et d'autres,
des études ont commencé à montrer la preuve de la neurogenèse,
la naissance de nouvelles cellules cérébrales
dans le cerveau des mammifères adultes,
d'abord dans le bulbe olfactif,
qui est responsable de notre sens de l'odorat,
puis dans l'hippocampe
impliquant la mémoire à court terme,
et enfin dans l'amygdale elle-même.
Afin de comprendre
comment ce processus fonctionne,
j'ai laissé les psychopathes et j'ai rejoint un labo à Oxford
spécialisé dans l'apprentissage et le développement.
Au lieu de psychopathes, j'ai étudié des souris,
parce que le même type de réponse du cerveau
apparaît dans beaucoup de différentes espèces d'animaux sociaux.
Donc, si vous élevez une souris dans une cage standard,
dans une boîte à chaussures avec de la ouate,
seule et sans beaucoup de stimulation,
non seulement elle ne se développe pas,
mais elle aura souvent des comportements étranges
et répétitifs.
Cet animal, naturellement sociable,
perdra sa capacité à se lier avec d'autres souris,
et deviendra agressif lorsqu'il est mis en leur présence.
Cependant, les souris élevées dans ce que nous appelions
un environnement enrichi,
un grand habitat avec d'autres souris
avec des roues et des échelles et des zones à explorer,
démontrent la neurogenèse,
la naissance de nouvelles cellules cérébrales,
et comme nous l'avons montré, elles accomplissent mieux
de nombreuses tâches d'apprentissage et de mémoire.
Maintenant, elles ne développent pas de moralité au point de
porter les sacs d'achats des petites souris âgées
dans la rue,
mais cet environnement enrichi résulte en comportements
plus sains et plus sociables.
Les souris élevées dans une cage standard, par contraste,
une cage semblable à une cellule de prison,
développent beaucoup moins de nouveaux neurones
dans le cerveau.
Il est maintenant clair que l'amygdale des mammifères,
y compris les primates comme nous,
peut montrer de la neurogenèse.
Dans certaines zones du cerveau,
plus de 20 % des cellules sont nouvellement formées.
Nous commençons tout juste à comprendre
quelle fonction exacte ont ces cellules,
mais ce que cela implique, c'est que le cerveau est capable
de changements extraordinaires y compris à l'âge adulte.
Cependant, nos cerveaux sont également
extrêmement sensibles au stress dans notre environnement.
Les hormones du stress, les glucocorticoïdes,
libérés par le cerveau,
inhibent la croissance de ces nouvelles cellules.
Plus il y a de stress, moins le cerveau se développe,
ce qui à son tour entraîne moins d'adaptabilité
et provoque plus de stress.
C'est l'interaction entre l'acquis et l'inné
en temps réel devant nos yeux.
Quand vous pensez à cela,
c'est ironique que notre solution actuelle
pour les personnes aux amygdales déficientes
est de les placer dans un environnement
qui en empêche effectivement toute possibilité de croissance.
Bien sûr, l'emprisonnement est une partie nécessaire
du système de justice pénale
et de protection de la société.
Notre recherche ne suggère pas
que les criminels doivent soumettre leurs examens IRM
comme preuve en cour
et soient disculpés car ils ont une amygdale défectueuse.
Les preuves vont en fait dans l'autre sens.
Parce que nos cerveaux sont capables de changements,
nous devons être responsables de nos actions,
et ils doivent assumer la responsabilité
de leur réhabilitation.
Cette réhabilitation peut se faire
grâce à des programmes de justice réparatrice.
Les victimes, si elles choisissent de participer,
et les coupables se rencontrent face à face
dans des endroits sûrs et structurés,
et le coupable est encouragé
d'assumer la responsabilité de ses actions,
et la victime joue un rôle actif dans le processus.
Dans un tel contexte, le coupable peut voir,
peut-être pour la première fois,
la victime comme une personne réelle
avec des pensées et des sentiments et une véritable
réponse émotionnelle.
Cela stimule l'amygdale
et peut-être une pratique de réadaptation plus efficace
que la simple incarcération.
Ces programmes ne fonctionnent pas pour tout le monde,
mais pour beaucoup, il pourrait être un moyen
pour briser la glace qu'ils entretiennent en eux.
Que pouvons-nous faire maintenant ?
Comment pouvons-nous mettre ces connaissances en pratique ?
J'aimerais vous laisser avec
trois leçons que j'ai apprises.
La première chose que j'ai apprise, c'est que
nous devons changer nos mentalités.
Depuis que Wormwood Scrubs a été construite il y a 130 ans,
la société a progressé dans presque tous les aspects,
dans la façon dont nous gérons nos écoles, nos hôpitaux.
Pourtant, au moment où nous parlons de prisons,
c'est comme si nous étions de retour à l'époque de Dickens,
si ce n'est pas l'époque médiévale.
Pendant trop longtemps, je crois,
nous étions convaincus
de la fausse idée que la nature humaine ne peut pas changer,
et en tant que société, cela nous coûte cher.
Nous savons que le cerveau est capable de changements extraordinaires,
et le meilleur moyen d'y parvenir,
même chez les adultes, est de changer et de moduler
notre environnement.
La deuxième chose que j'ai apprise,
c'est que nous devons réunir toutes les personnes
qui pensent que la science
peut aider à apporter des changements sociaux.
C'est assez facile pour un neuroscientifique de placer
un détenu de haute sécurité dans un scanner IRM.
Eh bien en fait, cela s'avère ne pas être si facile,
mais finalement ce que nous voulons montrer, c'est que
nous sommes peut-être en mesure de réduire les taux de récidive.
Afin de répondre à des questions complexes comme ça,
nous avons besoin de personnes de différents milieux --
les scientifiques et les cliniciens de laboratoire
les travailleurs sociaux et les décideurs politiques,
les philanthropes et les militants des Droits de l'Homme —
qui puissent travailler ensemble.
Enfin, je crois que nous devons
changer notre propre amygdale,
parce que cette question est au cœur
pas seulement de qui est Joe,
mais de qui nous sommes.
Nous devons changer notre vision de Joe
comme étant quelqu'un de totalement irrécupérable,
parce que si nous voyons Joe comme entièrement irrécupérable,
comment peut-il se voir autrement ?
D'ici dix ans, Joe sera libéré
de Wormwood Scrubs.
Sera-t-il parmi les 70 % de détenus
qui finissent par récidiver
et par revenir en prison ?
Ne serait-il pas mieux si, alors qu'il purge sa peine,
Joe réussisse à entraîner son amygdale,
ce qui stimulerait la croissance de nouvelles cellules cérébrales
et de leurs connexions,
de sorte qu'il sera en mesure de faire face au monde
une fois libéré ?
A coup sûr, ce serait dans notre intérêt à tous.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.